انتشر مقطع فيديو على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي في السودان واثار جدلا واسعا
المقطع والتقى رجليه دين بارزين وهما
ينثران الاموال في ساحه مسجد بمدينه ام
درمان
ناشطونستا من المشهد واعتبروا ان الاموال
المهدوره كانت اولى ان تذهب للفقراء
والمساكين
[موسيقى]
الزهور
تفاعل رواد مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي من
مشهد عفوي وجميل لرجل امن في المسجد
الحرام وهو يساعد احد الاطفال في لبس
الاحرام خلال دخوله الى ساحه الطواف
[موسيقى]
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
في ليبيا اثار مقطع فيديو داخل مسجد الجدل
امام يقف على المنبر يلقي خطه للناس بينما
في الجهه الاخرى من المسجد يقف امام اخر
وخلفه مجموعه من الناس يؤدون الصلاه
متداولين الفيديو شاركوا بعض التفاصيل حول
الحادثه مؤكدين انها حدثت في مسجد رقيبه
بمدينه اوباري حيث كان هناك خلاف في على
ائمه المسجد بين المصلين
[موسيقى]
الحمد لله والصلاه والسلام على
رسول الله صلى الله
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
تداول رواد مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي لحظات
الرعب التي عاشها مذيعي برنامج تلفزيوني
في الاكوادور بعد وقوع زلزال بقوه 6.8
درجه على الهواء مباشره نشاهد
[موسيقى]
مع محمود
كان هذا كل شيء لليوم الى اللقاء